welcome to this video I'll see door off
or aec door Fiona sometimes have issues
with those single letters tend to
pronounce them in the German way but
everybody goes Scott the little ticks
down okay I'm going with this mainline
Slav here he takes it yeah I recently
had a look at e3 you were just not super
dangerous but it's also not that bad
okay yeah the good thing is that this is
very simple to play we should be 2nite
over c1 to be three now that night has a
long long journey but i think it's it's
quite okay what the heck did who needs a
quick jump update in the middle of a
chess game huh why is why is he taking
so long maybe I could have played efore
by the way that would have been
interesting let's let's do that right
that it cannot be bad huh no I can be
bad but it doesn't look bad okay um if I
take now he's got Queen c7 yeah I was
thinking if t5 maybe is an option d5
takes takes going for that that pin
and will be Ruby an awkward to play for
black if I go 45 let's do it I'm not
quite sure if it if how good it is but
it's interesting okay so he's not taking
this I wasn't entirely sure he looked
very dangerous to take it but I wasn't
entirely sure how how problematic it
really is okay going for Knight b6 I
guess now a night here that's still a
bit of an issue I really have to replace
that thing hmm nice okay here it's
definitely okay because my night is
really terrible trying to get it to d2
now 95 is this idea
yeah definitely possible and h2 is
hanging yeah I don't really know do I
have time to even cover that I guess I
have to do this I like it if I needed
some time here like 92 and so on such
difficult Bishop a 6am okc 490 force
maybe not that terrible good night d 40
94 f 5 45 things like that
quite sure what this is doing really I
mean okay it looks active but is it that
helpful okay we will see maybe you can
go see for now but i was thinking 94
trying to take on the six and then do
something with that deep on Queenie to a
queen g4 is also interesting looking at
that look from Bishop f6 Knight f6 now
what about this takes Bishop takes isn't
that good for me mmm drinks drinks I
don't like you don't see how he offense
that check my queen f4 that's very lucky
that he has that move
very fortunate that he has that okay um
t6 t6 and 26 threatens d7 and them now
not quite sure maybe you can take on g6
and then then then March the sea pawn
something like that maybe I even had
something better than I don't know there
should be seven what what am I going to
do then I'd see Paul hmm
Brooksie one is got rookie one that's
not helping Bishop f6 maybe or oak b6 no
I have to be a bit quicker here be
difficult to play a perfectly anyway
this position
an active rook is nice I would have
liked to play Bishop f6 but he can take
f2 and the techs g2 immediately that
wasn't possible maybe f3 + f3 to keep em
out here and control you one now yeah
that was to be expected maybe c 3 takes
b3 is strong time morning
and happy three a strong look at you now
to get the apron to ship c-45 is rather
difficult actually to win in comparison
check
nice exceptionally slow draw a third I
don't offer twice and it assists and you
offer the draw once check game draw hey
it's a draw draw after on yeah hmm hmm
what a weird game I just didn't see
Bishop h2 coming we have something else
now I don't know I thought I might have
some chances here with this these pieces
on the on the on the Kings side probably
not uncheck it seems that this is not
working at all if you play the dried
bishops 8 is winning no should see a
does winning and rather simply actually
now that I look at it because I cannot
go to the seven because the back room
mate is killing me and here I'm just
lost
now that wasn't a really good position
here so it seems that that if or was a
bad idea I just should play the normal
moves like Bishop T 2 and so on now see
I've it's a problem yeah I mean if I
take it he goes here and well this hangs
and well the position opens up quickly
with my night being stuck on that
terrible square it is just not good now
but here I'm just suffering with that
vporn and the totally misplaced night 94
was a really bad idea oops I was a
really bad idea I got completely
outplayed after that okay well thanks
for watching